if you meet a person that's done 10
years of karate or Taekwondo or Judo or
jiu-jitsu
what different characters do they create
do different Arts create different types
of men and leaders based on what the
values and principles are or all of them
pretty much similar values and
principles
a good traditional background most of
the time like a Taekwondo or a karate
background you know those guys they
listen to instructions they're they're
more
I don't know more in control I would say
but then you need a good school as well
because you got a lot of schools like
for instance my daughters they went to a
school I won't say the name and they I
never saw them practice and suddenly
they had to go up for the yellow bell
test and they go and they're walking the
katas like this they have no clue what
they're doing and they received a bike
but the the yellow belt and the guy
comes to me and he says Hey
congratulations I said for what she says
for the belt I said they didn't get it
why would you give it to them you know
it makes no sense they did not know what
to do now this is it says oh we'll work
on it more I said no I'm out I said this
is a money making machine for you guys
you're just making money with a belt
system you pay 75 bucks you don't want
to do that now if you go to a school
like a for instance a cucuchin school
that's a different thing those guys when
you have a belt you have the belt so
it's all about what school you're going
to the most of the time is a really good
one and there's really good karate
karate schools as well regular karate
it's just about who's instructing okay
so so stay there so the so the the the
plate so one of it is the actual art
you're learning okay what I'm trying to
find out is you know you can go to uh
learning art and you may never make it
to the NBA you know the kids coach will
say like Mike one of the coaches for the
baseball team says you see all these
parents out here they all think their
son's going to be the next A-Rod what
they don't realize is their song's not
going to let them enjoy the game let
them have fun with baseball and he's
talking about this very few these guys
will end up being the next Alex
Rodriguez or whatever whatever 0.2 0.2
right to make it to that level right
okay but what I like about him as a
coach he's tough he's disciplined he
he's he challenges them we practiced
that he's he's really with them and he
loves on them he's got the balance of
both which I like so I put these guys
under Jujitsu and I see at the end of
the day hey what's the word of the day
discipline so yes they're learning how
to protect themselves but they're also
learning certain set of values and
principles you just said right now
Taekwondo karate is a lot of
coachability these are students that
develop coachability right you have to
memorize yeah but but I I what I want to
know is you meet a judo person
how different is a judo person 10 years
versus a karate and I'm talking that
they all have good teachers so we're not
talking about the bit we'll talk about
that here in a minute as well because
that's a paranoia I have as a parent
where like these guys are just making
money it's [ __ ] what they're doing
here but you meet a judo person you meet
a karate person you meet a Jujutsu
person and we go out with 10 Judo people
we go out with 10 karate people we'll go
out with 10 Jiu Jitsu people we go out
with 10 whatever pickles there's boxers
how different is their character you
know is one all about discipline is one
about you know spiritual is what what
what's the different DNA between these
different Arts I would say like the
Jujitsu and Judo will be more spiritual
you know if you go to Eddie Bravo's
classes I mean they light up a joint
before they start right everybody inside
if it's joints everybody flows better
there's one big bong in the middle
everyone thinks a hit literally yeah
oh my God I could see you enrolling in a
class like that right it's not good for
me but I wouldn't but so so those are
more the spiritual guys in the
combinations but you know you have them
everywhere that's what I'm trying to say
the more spiritual guys sorry
I would say in the Judo Jiu Jitsu
assemble all those kind of sports and
then karate once you start hitting
people I think you have the more energy
guys the more the ADD ADHD so those kind
of guys you have them there and they're
harder to coach because so this is who
this is this is karate or this is the
energy guys just punching and kicking
would be the energy got it because they
they picked that for a reason right your
big Jiu Jitsu you pick for a reason now
you pick it because you know it's a very
good self-defense we didn't know that
all the way back before you see it
before horse racing right you just
picked it because you don't like to get
hit right and you like this sport a lot
that's most of the time in but then you
start boxing and boxing you like to hit
people and those people are just
differently Wyatt you know they don't
care about getting hit themselves so
that's why at the beginning when you had
these Jiu Jitsu guys coming into MMA
they needed to get used to getting hit
while they're going for the submissions
because if they go for a submission but
they get hit in the face well that stops
of course the submission to them so so
is is there very interesting what you
just said so two questions one what
compliments what like it's good to take
like you know this with this yeah okay
that that's what to take or it's good to
start with this then to go to this which
and then I'll ask the next question for
you are there Arts that complement each
other very much um it's either a really
good strike I can do wrestling or you're
a really good submission guy you have
wrestling because if you have great
wrestling you you decide where the fight
is going to go you know so it's like
Chuck Liddell really good takedown
defense and he was just knocking people
out left and right worked really good
for him you have Damian Maya who's
really good on the ground could take
down takes people down and submits them
still till this day he will do that you
see so it's all a combination wrestling
should always be in the middle something
that I actually sucked at as a fighter I
just became really good on the ground
it's like when you read my like 42
submissions because it was a different
day but I never took anybody down so
that means that they took me down and
reversed them I would go for submission
wow you see so very interesting yeah
that's that's a complete so even though
you were not good at it the moment they
took you down you had 42 submissions
yeah in total at 42 submissions so you
were you were you were good at it but
you just how come you didn't do it if
you were good at it
oh no I did for the wrestling um why
don't you take them down if you were
good at it because I like to knock
people out as well okay so your Edge was
this was your analysis
so so I guess my second question for
this will be you talk about your
daughters right where they're going and
where you're putting me like hey what
are you doing no congrats this is the
last time you'll see me here you're just
running a business I get that feeling
sometimes like you're paying about money
it's just a business model that they're
creating
um how do you know the energy like my
oldest son he's more you know his energy
is a different kind of an energy my
younger son he's just like
he's like you're moving constantly right
now he's always like that he's always
moving right and you know so so to him
he needs to get that let that energy out
do you match an art with the kids energy
or no don't worry about it just put them
in there it's gonna be all right well
maybe you should do the opposite right
if you normally the guy who's toned down
he will just uh choose Jiu Jitsu but I
will put him in boxing them because then
he takes a little bit from the boxing
you see then you change a little bit
because it is good what he has but it
still needs to change you need to be
angry you need to be explosive at
certain moments calmness is everything
but there needs to be also a fuse that
you can set off right away and so you
start firing so the angry guy put him in
Jiu Jitsu Jiu Jitsu and the other guy
put him in boxing yeah very interesting
so Jennifer if you're listening
taking boxes but if they would choose
themselves yeah then the low level guy
will take Jiu Jitsu and then the high
level one naturally they're going to
want to so you mix them up so you I will
mix them up so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetamin it says future
looks bright here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red or black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]